stop being so hopeful expect that most
things are going to go wrong marriage
job holidays kids look at the glass
half-empty and then feel grateful
whenever things aren't an outright
catastrophe stop ranting about how awful
other people are most annoying people
aren't evil they're just anxious or sad
forgive them they didn't set out to hurt
you they're just under a lot of pressure
think of death a lot keep a skull on
your table you probably only got about
four hundred thousand hours yeah laugh
at yourself stop thinking of yourself as
a stupid idiot do something far nicer a
lovable fool make regular appointments
to talk with someone you don't spend
enough time with you ask yourself what
you really want and are anxious about
stop trying to make yourself happy it's
impossible for concentrate on cheering
up other people look at yourself as if
from the ISS 240 miles above the earth
from this height lots of things that are
bothering you look the size they should
always have been throw your phone off a
cliff for a bit so you can finally
notice stuff especially your partner and
your mum give up on the idea that you
should be normal the only normal people
are people you don't know yet
everyone is weird and that's totally
okay
you